[Music]
they happen in the privacy of our minds
pretty much everywhere at the pool the
conference the aisles of a supermarket
the dynamic is always the same very
little knowledge indeed complete
ignorance combined with a deep sense of
knowing them absolutely and of being
entirely certain they would if only
circumstances allowed be the one it's
been going on since early adolescence at
least does madness and even now when one
should know better it happens
these crushes they show up our capacity
of birth knowing how to make the most of
the smallest details a wrist a neck an
ankle a pair of jeans wore in a certain
way they instantly become whole people
with whom we can imagine years of a life
together full of profound mutual
sympathy tenderness and laughter this
blessed person will we know understand
us and all the secret complex ignored
parts of us this capacity we have for
elaborating a whole personality from a
few small details it's fair when we look
at sketches this isn't someone who has
no nostrils eight strands of hair and no
eyelashes
it's a beautiful creature we feel we
understand at once the cynics say it's
madness this filling in of the gaps
we're just projecting wild reckless
fantasies
but that's too sweeping we are probably
right to be delighted it's just not the
whole story
perhaps that remarkably thin wrist with
the leather band around it really does
belong to someone who is skeptical
alternative delicate intelligent wry the
error of the crush is to go beyond that
insight to think this could ever be the
whole truth about a human being knocked
off course by the crushes power we
forget one central inviolable fact of
human nature that everyone is crazy and
trouble to be around everyone has
something substantially wrong with them
everyone is extremely hard to live with
you can't know what from an ankle or
arrest but it'll be something time will
reveal it sure enough his life has
messed all of us up because we all grew
up in adequately parented and have all
ended up terrified and anxious pretty
much the whole time that's sad we
shouldn't give up on having crushes at
any age we just shouldn't believe in
what they appear to promise anymore
of course we haven't glimpsed complete
perfection it's just a pretty nice sight
or two coming to the fore
[Music]
you
you